mesdames et messieurs bonjour bienvenue
à cette édition de tam tam
alors tant de temps va être très chargé
aujourd'hui en un menu varié dans un
premier temps bon on parlera de ce qui
s'est passé au sein de l'assemblée des
premières nations qui ont déjà qu'ils
ont réélu la présidente
on parlera aussi de la crise au cambodge
avec l'implication de la diaspora
canadienne et on fera un tour au
festival de toronto qui n'a pas encore
été testée par des films de toronto mais
qui est venu déjà très alléchant pour
commencer on va parler d'un sujet qui
est très important pour nous ici ce
l'accueil des réfugiés
savez vous que le canada a d'un système
qui consistait comme généralement très
généreux mais est un système aussi de
rétention d'étrangers par le
gouvernement fédéral ce un système qui a
été revue avec la collaboration entre
autres du haut commissariat des nations
unies pour les réfugiés mais aussi et
surtout du conseil canadien pour les
réfugiés et pour en parler nous avons
avec nous la directrice exécutive du
conseil canadien pour les réfugiés janet
dench bonjour janet alors jen est
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'il fait des
problèmes avec le système de rétention b
réfugié au canada
le problème de base c'est que le canada
comme bien d'autres pays a tendance à
détenir très facilement dénis non
citoyens dont les laissant des
migrations et même dans les prisons
provinciales
donc en général il y a un droit à la
liberté
et puis on prend ça au sérieux dans des
pays comme le canada mais quand il
s'agit de non-citoyens x et quand il
s'agit de la loi sur l'immigration
on prend ça à la légère et puis on peut
très facilement un agent de
l'immigration peut très facilement
décider avant ces personnes là je vais
de détenir et ensuite il ya des
mécanismes de contrôle de détention mais
ça ne fonctionne pas comme il devrait
pour vraiment protéger le droit à la
liberté
donc nous
besoin vraiment de modifier radicalement
le système du point de vue du ceser pour
bien respecter le droit à la liberté de
tout le monde alors comment les choses
se font d'eux jusqu'à présent est ce que
les gens sont retenus sur la base de
critères particuliers où c'est vraiment
à la discrétion des agents d'immigration
il y a une base dans la loi donc mis à
des motifs de détention en général les
motifs qu'on voit le plus souvent c'est
triste fuite
donc lhi mygale l'agent dénégations ceux
d'yvon cette personne ne va pas se
présenter pour être expulsé du canada ou
pour les prochains et à un décès ces
procédures ou bien c est ça se passe
beaucoup ici à montréal on dit bon on
n'est pas satisfait de l'identité de la
personne ça arrive souvent à les
demandeurs d'asile des réfugiés qui ont
dû fuir avec les moyens de bord et qui
n'ont pas un document un passeport
vérifier et c est donc les agents
d'immigration 1 vont dire on n'est pas
nécessairement satisfait avec vos petits
documents donc on va vous de tenir en
attendant qu'on aille chercher ni preuve
de votre temps ça qu'on soit sûr que
vous êtes la personne que vous prétendez
être oui effectivement
oui il ya aussi des motifs pour danger
au public ou sécurité ça on les voit
moins souvent mais là encore il ya
souvent des problèmes parce que si
beaucoup d c'est à la discrétion des
agents de décider où se percevoir cette
personne-là représente un danger au
public puis évidemment il ya des
éléments de racisme qui entre dedans où
on va plus facilement jugé que quand une
personne de couleur elle représente
possiblement un danger au public qu'une
personne blanche
est-ce qu'on a une idée de la durée de
cette détention là habituellement ça
peut durer combien de temps oui il ya
des variations et nombre d'ont qu'il ya
des gens qui sont tenus pile relâché le
lendemain bien des portes et donc ça
peut arriver des gens qui arrivent au
aux aéroports du canada disent qu'ils
sont visiteurs et puis ensuite on n'y
croit pas on les met en détention puis
le lendemain on les renvoie un donneur
est d'origine à il y a des gens qui
passent quelques jours ou quelques
semaines on est tension et il ya aussi
un problème et ça ça a été découvert
récemment par un une étude approfondie
sur les décisions de la commission de
l'immigration et du statut de réfugié
donc la section d'initiation qui se pose
est contrôlé la détention
donc si détention à long terme donc des
personnes qui peuvent être en détention
pour cinq ans étant il ya pas de limite
et ça se passe surtout à toronto
on a deux beaux coups durs plus grand
problème avec les problèmes de détention
à long terme
comparé aux autres régions mais même ici
au québec par exemple ou encore une
britannique ont encore des gens qui
passent des années en détention est ce
que ces gens là sont maintenus dans le
cas d'une famille ensemble bien suspecte
ça serait comme aux états unis on sait
par les enfants des parents on reprend
maintenir tous les femmes la famille
ensemble quand il s'agit de mains du
maire et d'un père
donc on n'a pas comme aux etats-unis une
politique de ces arrêts les enfants des
parents mais ce qu'on va peut-être faire
dans une famille on peut des fois on va
détenir le père la mère et les enfants
sont libérés ou bien on va à m
l'air avec les enfants dans le centre de
détention puis peut voir peut-être une
fois par jour
le papa ou même moins fréquemment
donc il ya de la séparation des familles
mettent pas de la même façon aussi
brutale coke aux etats-unis est-ce qu'on
permet à des organismes comme le vôtre
d'avoir accès à ces gens là de voir dans
quelles conditions ils vivent donc il ya
deux façons de détenir les gens soient
dans un centre de détention qui géré par
l' agence des services frontaliers du
canada dont il y en a un à montréal et
un autre à toronto et dans les deux cas
oui il y à des ong qui ont une entente
avec l'organisme pour aller visiter le
centre des tensions
la situation est beaucoup mieux pour les
personnes qui sont détenues dans les
prisons provinciales parce que là ils
sont assujettis aux règles qui
concernent les prisons prisonniers donc
les personne accusée d'un crime et donc
que c'est beaucoup plus difficile
d'avoir accès il ya des règles très
strictes pour avoir accès à ces prisons
et en général les omci aux seins des
minivans pas donc il ya des personnes
des fois dans une stricte des situations
très très isolée
surtout si parle ni anglais ni français
ceux des situations extrêmement
difficiles
le ministre de la sécurité publique
un coup d'oeil il a pris un engagement
de minimiser le nombre de personnes qui
sont détenues dans les prisons un
provincial comme ça au moins c'est un
pas dans la bonne direction
alors on parle actuellement enfin entre
les janvier et mars il ya eu à peu près
2000 personnes qui ont été dans les
centres de détention de cette façon là
est ce que votre avec deux mille
personnes environ
cc c'est raisonnable où on aurait pu
faire beaucoup mieux à dire moins de
personnes pour nous on aimerait bien sûr
qu'il n'y ait plus de personnes en
détention
donc
nous on cherche pas vraiment à améliorer
la détention mais surtout à illuminer la
détention mais donc c'est sûr que on n'a
pas encore convaincu le gouvernement
canadien de passer à cette étape là donc
on est plus ce qu on voit actuellement
c'est plus des initiatives pour diminuer
la détention pour chercher des façons de
libérer certaines personnes et de lévis
tenir dans de meilleures conditions
à l'automne le canada a adopté ce qu'il
appelle la politique intéresse super de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
c'est à dire on essaie vraiment de
privilégier l'enfant est ce que vous
avez remarqué une différence depuis
l'adoption de cette politique là oui on
a heureusement vu une diminution du
nombre d'enfants qui sont détenus
surtout à toronto il ya eu un changement
assez radical est un parti
bon c'est sûr que c'est la volonté la
direction qui a dit un donnée par le
ministre mais il ya aussi une question
de des individus dont le système parce
que le système est il très
discrétionnaire tombe quand il ya des
agents qui veulent détenir ils peuvent
toujours faire trouver une raison pour
détenir quelqu'un puis à candé dit on à
un jazz à gens qui disent bon les
enfants n'ont pas leur place en
détention c'est aussi possible de
d'éviter la détention des enfants vont
alors vous vous avez quand même prépare
à un changement qui ont été mises en
place contre l on peut concrètement la
contribution du ccr c'était quoi dans
cette politique dans cette révision de
de politique de détention
c'est sûr que nous on collabore pas de
façon pratique quand on ne fait pas
partie du système du tout ce qu'on a
fait c'est que on a eu beaucoup de
conversations avec l' agence des
services frontaliers du canada alors
qu'ils préparaient leur projet puisque
nous c'était surtout pour insister sur
le fait que c'est pas juste
question de trouver des alternatives à
la détention mais c'est aussi de revoir
le système de prise de décision initiale
de détenir quelqu'un et deuxièmement on
voulait que le système soit d'argent et
ils soient basés dans la communauté donc
qu' on ne criminalise pas les personnes
détenues là dessus je pense pas qu'on a
vraiment gagné parce que des solutions
de rechange qui sont proposés sont
vraiment construit sur le modèle des
ressources criminelle dont on traite les
personnes détenues qui donc beaucoup
canon aucun aussi criminel mais on les
traite la même façon qu'on pouvait
traiter des criminels alors jamais
atteint ce plan politique bon il ya les
partis d'opposition qui reprochent au
gouvernement fédéral d'être laxiste dans
la gestion de cet afflux de migrants bon
du gréement du côté du gouvernement
fédéral
on réplique que les partis d'opposition
font une espèce de campagne de peur qu
en fin d information vous vous êtes une
partie neutre dans cette histoire là
quel est votre point de vue sur la
gestion de cette crise des crises entre
guillemets d'aider des migrants mais
malheureusement c'est le genre de
discours qu'on trouve trop souvent dans
ce pays au monde où on va chercher 10
des bénéfices politiques en tapant sur
l'immigrant il est réfugié en les
présentant comme une menace à la société
alors que les réfugiés et les immigrants
contribuer de façon spectaculaire à
notre société en général au canada on a
eu la chance de ne pas avoir trop de
politiciens qui essayent de gagner les
élections sur les dons des réfugiés mais
on n'est pas à l'abri de ce genre de
manipulation politique donc je pense que
c'est la responsabilité de tout le monde
de lutter contre ça et de parler des
réfugiés de leurs demandes de protection
un de façon éclairée et
neutre on ne prenons pas en n'utilisant
pas des mots comme crise alors que c'est
si si vraiment pas approprié dans le
contexte tout à fait s'est passé autour
de la table quand une question pour
diane aide
j'aimerais savoir parce que quand on met
les gens comme ça dans des prisons
provinciales
est-ce qu'ils sont isolés ils sont mis à
part os qui sont mélangés avec les
prisonniers de droit commun comment ça
se passe oui ça c'est une excellente
question
ça c'est quelque chose qui est critiquée
par les nations unies du canada on va
prendre des personnes détenues en raison
de doutes de la loi sur l'immigration
ils émettent ils ça peut être aussi des
réfugiés on va les mettre dans les
prisons où il côtoie lee prisonniers
criminels
donc oui il y a un problème il ya aussi
le problème que si on va les isoler et
ils risquent aussi de d'être isolé de
tout le monde donc par exemple s'il n'y
a pas de d'autres personnes détenues ont
des dents en fonction de la loi sur les
mines à 100 et peut se trouver en
isolement qui est aussi ça peut être une
forme de torture également donc de notre
point de vue il faudrait vraiment éviter
ce genre de détention donc voilà
alléchante halouze avait une question
juste une petite question concernant les
indices qui peuvent amener les agents
des services frontaliers a disons à
détenir un migrant sous prétexte que la
personne peut s'enfuir
quels sont les indices qui peuvent
pousser à penser que quelqu'un ou pas
s'enfuir
c'est une excellente question encore une
fois puis sicilia au vraiment de réponse
parce que l'agent va se poser m'en
prendre en compte tous les facteurs du
dossier mais nous on avait on a insisté
beaucoup avec l'agent ce qu' il faut pas
que ce soit très
et lorsqu'il n'y a pas de critère klein
c'est sûr que ça revient à l'ampli
traire on a beaucoup d'instinct ou
quelqu'un qui a demandé le statut de
réfugié dans la demande a été refusée
donc il fait face à la détention la
personne se présente à son entrevue pour
organiser son renvoi est l'agent va lui
demander est-ce que vous avez parle de
retourner dans votre pays
puis la personne dit oui j'ai peur et
ensuite l'agent va démarrer
si vous avez peur de retourner ça veut
dire que probable moyen est ce que vous
allez pas vous présenter pour votre
renvoi est sur cette base là va détenir
la personne donc c'est quelque chose que
nos membres souvent le conseil aux
personnes avant de passer ne dit jamais
que vous avez peur de retourner dans
votre pays
parce que sinon vous restiez l'a dit en
riant absolument
voilà en tout cas c'était très très
éclairant jamais dit je rappelle que
vous êtes la directrice exécutive du
conseil canadien pour les réfugiés
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
nous parler surtout d'éclairer nos
lanternes sur ce sujet très important
merci merci
voilà alors maintenant rester entre nous
et je me dirige vers vos laurent spinosi
bonjour laurent jours à laurence bon il
ya une élection à vancouver pour
déterminer le chef de l'assemblée de
l'assemblée nationale des premières
nations partenaires sont des
déprédations organisations autochtones
qui influence une forte influence très
bien aussi sur pays etc perry bellegarde
qui était réélu pour un deuxième mandat
vous avez suivi tout ça pour nous depuis
le début malgré sa victoire à belgrade
est quand même très content et très
contestée dans
les communautés alors il faut juste
expliquer un peu c'est quoi la peine
c'est vraiment là l'organisation tonnes
à plus influente du pays c'est un groupe
de pression qui est chargé de défendre
les intérêts des premières nations selon
les directives de ses membres alors le
plus souvent ça implique de faire
pression sur le gouvernement fédéral
dans des domaines tels que les soins de
santé les infrastructures le territoire
l'éducation et donc ces élections là qui
ont eu ou trois ans et plus de 600 chefs
ou peut-être moins 6 et pop tous les
chefs qui s'inscrivent ils leurs
représentants qui votent donc que ce
n'est pas un vote de la population ce
qui est quelque chose qui comme vous
avez des grands électeurs au com aux
etats-unis
exactement exactement donc cette époque
c'est pas quelque chose qui fait
l'unanimité
alors oui donc perry bellegarde remporté
l'élection c'était le candidat favori
il est donc sorti vainqueur au deuxième
tour du scrutin avec plus de 60% des
voix 63 % pour être plus exact et perry
bellegarde
il est de la première nation de l'est
dont blackburn saskatchewan et il est
très près du gouvernement trudeau c'est
justement ce qu'on lui reproche donc
vous disiez un peu plus tôt et les
traits il est très contestée par les
autres candidats
et justement là qui sont ils ces autres
candidats qu'il a dû affronter alors est
d'abord y avait parmi ses principaux
rivaux y avait celle en or qui est une
une grande chef du manitoba c'est une
ancienne aussi de s'immiscer de
cityville marzouki et ancien président
de la nation haïda en colombie
britannique
et il ya aussi catherine noailles club
du manitoba est plus près de chez nous
monsieur gbagbo qui est un analyste
politique de gannat wagué avec beaucoup
d'années d'expérience et c'est quelqu'un
peut plus est qui qui qui reproche
beaucoup de choses donc à perry
bellegarde ont tous les candidats on
reprochait fait à bagard d'être auprès
du gouvernement trudeau de ne pas agir
avec l'organisation comme que
l'organisation nagy donc plus comme
comme un groupe de lobbying un groupe de
pression qui n'est plus indépendant est
aussi nourri reproche à perry bellegarde
de ne pas assez donné le pouvoir aux
communautés autochtones
en gros ils disent qu à bellegarde mais
c'est une extension du gouvernement et
que c'est un
groupe de coloniser pour ils ont dit
colonisé une des candidates a dit le mot
colonisés en même temps on peut se poser
la question est ce que la proche on va
dire bulldozers face au gouvernement
fédéral
c'est à dire l'absence de collaboration
est ce que c'est une approche qui est
forcément positive est ce qu'on peut
gagner des choses de cette façon
c'est exactement ce que dit bellegarde
lui il dit je ne pourrais pas avoir
cette approche là bulldozers et il faut
que le choix près du gouvernement et lui
dit en fait je vais parler juste juste
avant il dit moi je suis prêt de enjoy
chirurgie auprès des dinos erik
démocrates dont c'est ce que lui dit
mais bon alors je vous donne des
citations
il dit même que bellegarde représente
une menace à présent pour les droits des
autochtones chez lanouette a dit pendant
sa campagne on a besoin d'un chef qui
peut s'asseoir à la table avec les
libéraux sans en devenir un été avec le
gouvernement fédéral il ya quand même
lieu de se poser quelques questions par
rapport
je veux dire à son indépendance
vis-à-vis de certaines revendications de
la population autochtone parce que les
gens demandent que leurs droits soient
respectés en ce qui concerne certains
traités ancestraux est-ce que c'est
véritablement le meilleur porte parole
pour cette population là donc on peut
dire que ça en même temps là comme ils
se sentent pas pour 112 voir donc ça va
il a été fortement et lucas démocratie
par d'autres chefs
voilà sans doute chez japon pas
forcément par la populace population
exactement
alors maintenant donc il a gagné le jour
même de l'élection la tension tht est
quand même très très vives
oui oui oui alors on a parlé c'est
vraiment le sujet de discussion des 24
dernières heures la ministre pendant la
journée du vote la menace des relations
la couronne et les autochtones carolyn
bennett
elle a été présente à l'assemblée à
vancouver et elle a rencontré des chefs
un groupe de chefs du manitoba et donc
ç'a vraiment été perçu comme de
l'ingérence politique par les autres
candidats
il ya deux candidats
la première fois que je vois un ministre
influencer les chèvres le jour du vote
je considère cela comme de l'ingérence
politique et donc le lendemain donc hier
la ministre est vu obligé de se défendre
lors d'un point de presse dit j'ai trop
de respect pour vous pour essayer
d'influencer vos décisions
en parlant avec avec le chef bellegarde
tout à l'heure il me dit ah ben c'est
normal les chefs peuvent inviter qu'ils
veulent et puis son édition ils sont
juste frustré parce qu'ils ont perdu en
gros c'est ce qu'il a dit alors ça ça
montre vraiment l'attention qu'il y a
entre entre bellegarde les autres les
autres candidats qui ont perdus et aussi
la population maintenant monsieur garder
là il va l'être
enfin il continue à être le grand chef
c'est quoi la suite des choses
alors on peut s'attendre vraiment un
statu quo une relation fructueuse donc
avec le gouvernement trudeau a comparé
aux années un peu la peine se réunit
beaucoup plus avec le cabinet beaucoup
plus de ressources notamment monétaires
le budget de l'apn est environ 30
millions c'est beaucoup plus que sourire
peut donc perry bellegarde bail
il m'a pas il me parlait tout à l'heure
il me disait belge
il va il faut continuer sur ces dossiers
par exemple la protection des langues
autochtones c'est un dossier qui avance
effectivement il a dit il eu des
réunions avec avec la minute jeudi avec
le gouvernement la blessure fait sa
protection de l'enfance bon c'est déçu
cdd des dossiers qu'ils continuent de
faire avancer
mais comme on disait tout à l'heure en
fait c'est ça le ultime on la peine
c'est un produit de la structure
coloniale comme les conseils de bande et
la loi sur les indiens
le malaise par rapport à cette
organisation persiste quand même dans
les communautés de quand on voit un peu
les cantons celui par exemple les
entrevues de monsieur bellegarde on voit
les commentaires sur internet et
monsieur bellegarde est en entrevue
r avec ses piscines de jeunesse en
facebook life et les commentaires
étaient vraiment très critique
on le traite de [ __ ] mais est ce que
peut-être la solution serait quand même
plus elle chante à la liste un b le
suggérer c'est à dire peut-être aller au
suffrage universel faire en sorte que le
chef soit vraiment il lui parle dans la
population et non par une bâche afin pas
régi par les autres chaufferie c'est une
question qui revient souvent mais je
crois qu'elle n'ait pas étudié
sérieusement comment comment il va faire
pour travailler avec cette consteste
contestation ces soucis qui il est
contesté mais depuis longtemps et puis
finalement six essais les gens si ce
n'est pas les citoyens qui votent pour
lui alors oui délicat ben il peut
continuer à vous il peut continuer toute
façon c'est un groupe de lobbying alors
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas le
gouvernement je n'ai pas eu député sais
pas parlons passons d'une contestation à
une autre cette fois là de l'autre côté
à l'autre bout du monde c'est au
cambodge
sur le plan politique il ya beaucoup
d'agitation et l'agitation est telle que
la diaspora
ici au canada est très très sensibilisée
à ce qui se passe là bas elle aurait agi
dans ce sens de ce qu'ils avaient suivi
ali chantal qu'est ce qui se passe
exactement en fait c'est un dossier que
j'ai suivi avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'intérêt donc c'est la diaspora
canadienne la diaspora aux états unis en
europe également c'est vraiment tout ce
monde là qui est mobilisée contre cette
élection qui est très très contestée
c'est une élection qui aura lieu dans
quelques jours élection c'est des
élections nationales non on a les
législatives
et donc on a un premier ministre qui est
au pouvoir depuis plus de 30 ans et qui
fait tout et tout pour y rester et donc
la population est contre mais n'osent
pas parler parce que on est dans une
espèce de république bananière où les
gens sont muselés la presse est muselée
les gens n'ont pas le droit de se réunit
de se rassembler de discuter le mans ne
serait ce qu'un petit groupe dès qu'il
ya deux trois quatre personnes qui se
réunissent au coin de la rue pour se
dire deux mots ils sont tout de suite
arrêté sont arrêtés ils sont molesti
sont battus
reçus de monsieur socali parce que c'est
avec lui que je me suis entretenu hier
s'ils se qualifient et qui coordonne le
mouvement le mouvement de la diaspora
qui se mobilisent donc pour contester
cette élection là et donc monsieur
saccani m'a transmis des images
horribles
on se croirait dans un film
apocalyptique où des gens sont battus on
a du sang qui coule
et puis franchement à la répression
policière est à son comble dans ce pays
alors la diaspora cymes que du côté des
autorités canadiennes et cela commence à
avoir des réactions à ce qui se passe là
bas
jusqu'à présent j'ai pas de réaction est
justement la mobilisation vise à
sensibiliser la communauté
internationale et les responsables
politiques canadiens pour qu'ils fassent
pression sur le pouvoir en place dans ce
pays il a ce pouvoir est appelée à
lâcher un peu du lest comme on le dit
souvent parce que la population croupit
dans une misère sans précédent c'est des
gens qui sont malades qui ont faim qui
n'ont pas accès aux soins dont ils ont
donc ils ont besoin et les jeunes sont
contraints à l'exil
franchement c'est une situation
invivable dans ce pays d'après les échos
que vous avez us que pour l'instant
c'est surtout la diaspora qui
s'impliquent où on va dire au canada par
exemple et non cambodgien les québécois
les canadiens qui ne sont pas qu'ils
n'ont pas des liens briques en beauté ce
que si aucun son de cloche de ce côté là
mais tu joues est il que les
organisations internationales sont
mobilisés on a amnistié internationale
qui a fait tout cadré c'est tout un
portrait vraiment alarmant ou alarmistes
de la situation c'est un portrait
vraiment très très peu rassurant on a
des gens qui vivent avec moins de 100
dollars par mois vous imaginez
c'est une situation totalement invivable
pour la population il ya également les
nations unies qui appelle le premier
ministre comment il s'appelle déjà c'est
une scène et on lui demande vraiment de
faire attention avec sa politique de
répression parce que c'est l'armée qui
est monté contre la population
pratiquement et puis les les opposants
sont usés ils sont arrêtés ils sont
incarcérés pour rien l'unique parti de
l'opposition enfin je veux dire le parti
qui compte sur la scène politique a été
interdite et sans son leader incarcéré
interdits de tout mouvement politique
pendant que
5 quand vous comprenez c'est une
situation vraiment vraiment difficile
pour ces peuples et là en tout cas va
compter deux succès merci d'être venus
nous raconter ça parce que vous savez
c'est un dossier qui qui commence et
donc la sensibilisation n'est pas encore
au maximum et c'est bon c'est bon d'en
parler pour justement attire l'attention
là dessus alors on va terminer avec un
sujet beaucoup plus léger mais non moins
intéressant alors ismaël bientôt ça va
être au rendez vous annuel à toronto
c'est l'un des plus grands rendez vous
en tout cas le rendez vous du cinéma
canadien
le festival international du film de
toronto cette semaine on a dévoilé la
programmation avec la présence de kim
guyenne alors qu'ils ne deviennent qui
est un réalisateur bien connu ici c'est
un fait quel est le film que ça il a
présenté un film qui va représenter le
canada en fait tout à fait donc kim
nguyen qui on confond se souvient de son
fils rebelle qui était finaliste aux
oscars en 2013 quand même donc il nous
revient avec son nouvel opus qui va être
présenté au festival international du
film de toronto c'est l'un des plus gros
festivals au mans c'est le festival qui
prépare à la cérémonie des oscars d'un
certain film se retrouve en lice ensuite
en février à cette cérémonie
prestigieuse
donc voilà kim nguyen son nouveau film
qu'on attendait behind the project qui
met quand même à la fiche je l'entends
bien là c'est herman très important
parce que c'est jesse eisenberg à
l'excellent de seize gardes et salma
hayek un peu vraiment particulier tiré
d'une histoire vraie où on est catapulté
dans un opus où deux cousins new yorkais
temps de creuser un tunnel pour faire
passer un fil à une fibre optique qui
permettra de gagner des milices secondes
en ce qui concerne les transactions
boursières donc c'est assez compliqué
comme ça mais c'est surtout comme le dit
kim nguyen en communiqué de presse un
film très humain un film qui va
s'attarder sur le destin de personnes
qui prend qui prennent des paris fous et
qui avec ses parts il faut peut-être
font changer un peu le monde
le réalisateur canadien qui vont être à
l'affiché à l'eau le festival du film de
toronto a présenté les films qui seront
dans les galas où les événements
spéciaux donc on n'a pas encore la
programmation complète donc hormis kim
nguyen il ya quand même le réalisateur
d'origine montréalaise jason reitman qui
revient lui aussi avec un film en langue
anglaise de frontrunner qui met aussi l
affiche une grande vedette américaine
hugh jackman sur fond de scandale et
d'adultère donc c'est vraiment assez
intéressant de voir quand même que nos
réalisateurs s'exporte et font des
grosses productions avec des grandes
têtes d'affiché
voilà alors bon le programme vise aussi
à comprendre
après il ya un programme qui était on va
dire annoncé l'investissement du
gouvernement du québec 2 millions de
dollars dans la création d'un programme
scientifique qui va être basé à
l'université du québec en outaouais ce
un programme qui vise à comprendre quels
impacts néfastes
on les fait je pense que je suis en
train de lui parler les autres d'autres
choses des bélougas voilà c'est pas le
sujet non mais c'est le même le même
moteur mal ah oui et travaillé cette
semaine quand même une annonce
importante concernant du compte que les
bruits mettait en péril le bien-être et
la vie des bélougas les bélougas fait
les baleines blanches de l'estuaire du
saint laurent qui sont en voie de
disparition c'est une espèce menacée
menacé et l'esc la sous-espèce des
bélougas du saint laurent sont seulement
2000 individus donc c'est très peu et on
s'est rendu compte évidemment que le
bruit des bateaux mettait à mal leur
survie donc le gouvernement du québec a
annoncé un investissement de 2 millions
$ à l'université du québec en outaouais
pour permettre de confectionner ou de
mettre en place une sorte de de deux
machines ou de recherche scientifique
qui permettrait de voir les impacts de
ces bruits de navires mais de
précisément de mettre en lumière ce que
les bélougas reçoivent comme impact
néfaste et ainsi peut-être permettre au
bateau pêcheur ou autre ne changerez
père et plus facilement elle changé le
learning curve ou même le bruit dès 9h
ou peut-être de les minimiser
et ainsi permettre la survie de son
succès c'est très bien les onze est très
silencieux aujourd'hui
écoutez d'abord vous et c'est que vous
êtes monsieur technologie quand même et
les difficultés du côté de discuter en
bourse avec des compagnies comme
facebook trahit bien de tomber
voilà alors c'est la première fois
depuis dix ans qui ont à maintes
reprises comme sur les tombes de cette
façon de l'intérieur c'était ça fait dix
ans à peu près qui en fait c'est
l'histoire de la sécurité toujours c'est
l'histoire de toutes les choses qui ont
entraîné met en place pour essayer d et
de retenir les gens les gens c'est sans
voix ils veulent plus mettre du contenu
qui mettent des informations qui vont
être vendues après pour d'autres choses
là alors c'est ça la plupart des
utilisations comme un pays chaud d après
les révélations qui a eu mais celui que
ceux qui sont au courant savez enfin ils
ne sont pas surpris par toutes les
révélations qu'il ya eu suite
en fait je connais des gens qui disent
se situe le parc étant contenus soient
partagées dans ses réseaux sociaux
soit pas partie des réseaux sociaux à
savoir de facebook autour de la table et
qui on rapporte que moi je suis
maintenant ça fait une aide n'est une
que je ne participe plus je les vois je
suis là par une des questions de travail
mais je gêne à la jce pas un facebook
j'aimais plus de contenu mais c'est une
décision qui était à reprises avant
l'histoire des des fuites d informations
mais quand même je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus simple
vraiment on se rend compte et on est
trop là d'un pionnier et puis il faut il
faut laisser la place pour ces gens de
choses
côtoyer des gens n'aimaient pas de
contenu on est obligé d'y être comme
journée si ça on va y puiser des
nouvelles à prendre mais c'est quand
même peu tiraillé histoire départager
tout le temps d'essayer d'y être là des
ddd participer non mais il faut éviter
l'obsession l'obsession facebook y aller
un état de nécessité
est ce que j'en ai besoin aujourd'hui
oui dans le cadre de mon travail mais
dire que je vais partager des
informations personnelles mais parce
qu'il faut y réfléchir et de partage
d'informations personnelles je fais un
papier pour la section espagnole qui me
parlait justement que les grands les
quatre grands c'est à dire microsoft
facebook google et twitter
ils sont en train de faire de sorte que
on va pouvoir se partager la base de
données de chaque personne c'est à dire
que moi je vais migrer toutes mes
contenus des facebook vers google je
peux le faire
en fait c'est une projets sont en train
de construire la façon de le faire les
structures pour les faire ça va le
facile des pouvoirs je veux plus
facebook je vais être un google je veux
sans toutes les informations facebook je
les porte sur google mais je pense que
ça va être toute l'information partagée
par tout le monde avance et souvent dire
que facebook c'est une entreprise privée
quand on signe un contrat avec facebook
donne des informations à une entreprise
et iv et elvis est ces informations la
pression mais comment se fait il que ce
soit gratuit
comment se fait-il que je peux être là
pendant des heures la gratuité en fait
c'est nous qui qu'alimente ans par le
contenu ce qui nous sommes le produit
c'est ça que j'allais justement à 20 il
ne vendait des piles nous vendait des
produits maintenant nous montrer le
produit ces informations mais mais mais
c'est un sujet vraiment passionnant et
puis avec le temps je pense que facebook
ne lâchera pas même s'ils perdent et
pourcentage ou quelques milliards à la
bourse
facebook se défendre a très bien mais
c'est aussi au niveau des jeunes et puis
au niveau des enfants au niveau de tout
c'est cette population très sensible
auquel facebook ou s'ils utilisent la
matière grise où les le produit et sa
faut faire très attention en fait dix
ans qu'elle est la population les jeunes
puis les enfants ne sont pas tout à fait
sur facebook qui utilisent d'autres
libres et justes vont davantage je
voyais du compte et ça fait comme
twitter c'est beaucoup plus pour
harceler déjà définition du twitter les
gens qui sont sur facebook
c'était normalement pour approcher les
gens mais ça ça fait quelques mois que
ça monte pas la quantité de gens qui
jusque là à facebook alors c'est quelque
chose
alors laurent vous êtes une abonnés de
facebook j'imagine même en fait avec
facebook c'est vraiment pour avoir de
l'information
c'est ça c'est sûr je pense que c'est ça
la différence avec avant facebook avant
s'est plaint un carnet personnel
et où les gens s d'album en album on
mettait des photos alors qu'avec le
temps maintenant les dernières années
c'est devenu une façon de demas brevet
en information je pense que c'est ce
pour plusieurs personnes
mais si l'algorithme a changé il y est
fait et les scellés d'une nouvelle des
côtés oui je m'en donnait l'algorithme
est chargée puis on laissait les
nouvelles déconvenues
donc si il ya très peu de chances que je
vois cela démange et hier avec qui vous
avez joué aux cartes ou bien on avait
cette tendance là donc c'était comme un
espace d'expression pour cette un
narcissique qui venait là l excellence
vendre trop voilà alors oui mais non je
mets dans tous les cas nous sommes assez
avertis pour ne pas tomber dans le piège
de l'exhibitionnisme sur les réseaux
sociaux
mais il ya tout ce que je pense aussi
que c'est la partie visible de l'iceberg
parce qu'il ya et à ce qu'on fait ce
qu'on écrit et tout ça mais il ya aussi
tous et toutes ses options que facebook
mais en secret pour pour analyser nous
nous donnons geste même nom nos
habitudes de consommation à déformer les
commerçants de l'autre
et puis quand on ouvre notre facebook
n'importe où on se retrouve dans le
monde on a un accès au gps qui
totalement nous localiser ce sont ces
informations secrètes
oui tout à fait plus de ça les gens qui
sont pas abonnés à facebook et ils
peuvent être tracés par nom qui on est
retenez donc on a parlé sur rendu compte
au jeu je fais l'exercice dans le lot de
toute l'information que j'ai remis un
facebook après l'histoire dé cambridge
analytique
j'ai trouvé en fait je download est qu
un guide d'information
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
d'informations oui oui puis j'ai su ça
leur est tracée l'information
particulière que j'ai vu que ma base de
données démonter les fonds c'est-à-dire
tous les gens que j'ai dans mes carnets
un des communications sont là dedans et
je dis pourquoi pas je cherchais un
petit peu puis j'ai fouillé puis j'ai
trouvé que l'histoire c'est que heu là
ces données de facebook qui prend le
téléphone qui sont mes amis par exemple
un carnet d'adressés qui après il va
creuser l'élève en fait y va il va faire
un an facebook icaunais même déjà qu'ils
sont pas sur facebook il ya lieu de se
poser des questions mais qui lit les
contrats d'adhésion à facebook si les
îles qui sont en fait les deux mois
après cambridge analytique edge je sais
pas si dit il c'est à toi ton cas mais
pas moi ils m'ont bombardé avec des
nouvelles clauses de confidentialité
puis fallait les lire la c6 et ces deux
là sont également j'essaie de les lire
c'est vrai nous décourager qui font
beaucoup rire et constitue se passe
quand on voit les allait fonctionner
mais on ne passe pas toujours
[Musique]
ça vaut la peine d'aller lire de porter
ses lunettes et d'aller vraiment entre
les lignes pour éviter de tomber dans
certains types de piles mais quand même
il faudrait avoir au moins la l'aide de
sa blessure qui sont difficiles à saisir
à maîtriser mais quand même ça vaut la
peine ça vaut la peine d'y aller devoir
de chercher à comprendre de quoi il
s'agit
avant de mettre savoir doser sa petite
signature la question qui va se poser
c'est est-ce qu'après avoir lu cette
information là est ce qu'on est pas
renoncé à facebook une fois qu'on est au
coin de ces choses là ou pas mais
l'histoire c'est comme ami alors mais
l'information n'est toujours link est en
moi je suis dise pas que j'ai passé tout
mon profil mais l'information est
compliqué parce que toi tant que le
téléphone à moi dans ton téléphone
mais bah voilà la question que pose
didier est ce qu'on devrait renoncer à
facebook dans notre cas je pense que non
n'est pas grave casual la personne qui
lit et qui au courant qu'ils se
racontent quelque chose qui cloche elle
pourrait découvrir de sérieux surprise
alors voilà et des coûts des surprises
donc mais par rapport à
id l'intérêt de communiquer avec les
amis la famille les autres les autres
avantages de facebook
est ce que la personne est prête à
renoncer à ces avantages la et sachant
très bien que il ya des risques et des
inconvénients par rapport à sa vie
privée
mais une chose est sûre s'il ya beaucoup
trop de pièges peut-être en serait prêt
à renoncer à certaines choses il
faudrait wiba examen revoir la façon de
publier qu'est-ce que je publie
qu'est-ce que je publie pas qu'est-ce
que je suis prête à sacrifier au nom de
ma vie privée
au nom de la préservation de ma vie
privée de mes informations personnelles
que je gagne par rapport à qu'est-ce que
je perds la balance des dieux en tout
cas c'est une discussion qui est
passionnante
on passerait toute la journée à paris
mais vous savez c'est des grands
professionnels tous les tous les quatre
ici ils ont des choses à faire leur
journée n'est pas finie au contraire
peut-être que commencer
ismaël a dit chantal laurence léo merci
beaucoup merci merci beaucoup conjoint
bonne journée